when i heard that this uh man was uh uh
available to chat cause he's got his
memoir out i said absolutely
uh a legend in the world of journalism
and at this point is when i i take my uh
my graduate degree from the madill
school of journalism of northwestern i
take that out and i say this is what
i've got going on
for my bona fides to interview this man
uh chasing history a kid in the newsroom
where all books are sold carl bernstein
here on the rich eisen show how are you
good it's sir to be with you and you're
talking about larry o'brien
he was aside from being the commissioner
that's it
yeah he was during at the time of the
watergate break-in he was the chairman
of the democratic national committee and
they were the burglaries were trying to
find out things that larry o'brien knew
and that had nothing to do with wilt
chamberlain at the time or anything like
that right
no and the burglars were short
so
um
honestly i i bring that up all the time
and people can't believe that there is a
watergate connection to the to the
trophy that the nba champions left every
single year but so did you did you ever
interview the uh
larry o'brien when he was the dnc did
you ever knock on his door when you and
uh yeah
i i i talked to him a good number of
times uh
opening his capacity as chairman of the
democratic national committee and as the
intended
uh person who who the burglars wanted to
hear
what he was saying and as well as other
people but he was one of the objects of
of the burglary i mean the other thing
i'm just thinking about about being on
this show and
about you know the book
called chasing history a kid in the
newsroom it's about growing up uh and an
apprenticeship
in this great newsroom at the washington
evening star between 60 and 65 and one
of the things i got to
do was to get to know the great great
sports writers of the day
bob addy shirley kovich
red
uh you know it was an amazing time of
sports writing
carl bernstein here uh on the on the
rich eisen show so um so this book just
focuses on on you growing up what what
what um led you to
the career that that you
you wound up having carl what about that
well i i'm a second generation native
washingtonian and uh when i was a junior
in high school
i had one foot in the classroom one foot
in the juvenile court
one one foot in the pool hall
it's three feet but the one in the
foot that was in the classroom was about
two inches in
and my father rightly feared for my my
future and he knew somebody at the
washington evening star the great
afternoon newspaper in washington the
opposition paper to the washington post
and at that time a better paper than the
washington post and my father knew i had
taken a journalism class in the 10th
grade and i had some ability to write i
could pass essay exams uh while failing
everything else
and he got me an interview for a job as
a copy boy
and and i've never seen the inside of a
newsroom and when i went through the
interview
the person who interviewed me the
production editor of the paper took me
into the newsroom and i had never seen
such a sight in my life and to this day
it's probably the most stunning thing
i've ever encountered there was noise
people were yelling copy
clattering typewriters you could hear
the rumble of the presses underneath
a copy boy came by with a wagon full of
the fifth edition of the newspaper that
day and and the production editor handed
me one of one copy and it was still
warned from the presses and watching the
spectacles within these people were on
the most urgent errands in the nation
i knew in that instance that i wanted to
be a newspaper man and though i was much
younger than
pretty much everybody there the other
copy boys were 20 21
uh i went to work there i got hired
because i had taken typing with the
girls and could type 90 words a minute
uh and
i then got the greatest seat in the
country had an amazing time in america
and in the nation's capital carl
bernstein pulitzer prize winning
journalist in the author of his new
memoir chasing history a kid in the
newsroom when did you realize the
watergate story was something different
when did you realize that carl
i think both bob woodward and myself
realized that even the first day after
the break-in bob was at the
courthouse covering the arraignment of
the burglars and one of them said he
worked for the cia and bob said holy
[ __ ]
you can see that scene right in the
movie of all the president's men were
reading the book uh meanwhile i was in
the office and i started calling the
homes
and wives of the watergate burglars who
were from florida most of them were
cuban americans
and some of the wives started telling me
about their husbands six
cia connections so
initially
our feeling was that this might really
just break in and burglary with five men
are arresting wearing rubber gloves and
business suits and sequential
hundred dollar bills in their pockets
but this might go to the cia somehow not
to to the nixon white house but within a
few days it became evident to us that
somehow this pointed toward the nixon
white house and re-election committee
well at some point are we gonna people
have obviously seen the film and have
read the book um but
at some point um
was there uh a breaking point where
you know where you felt
that this could ruin your career if not
also break a story that that you were on
thin ice
on this time
yes we made a mistake and you know
people ask all the time were we afraid
for our lives and there were some
moments when we got some threats that
weren't quite so veiled
but really what were we afraid of we're
afraid of making a mistake because the
the future of the paper
uh
if we made a bad mistake that the paper
itself could suffer
grievously and maybe irretrievably
because the white house had made our
conduct woodward myself ben bradley the
great editor of the washington post they
made our conduct and watergate the issue
instead of the conduct of the president
and his men and we made a mistake it
turned out it was a mistake of
attribution we had said that
somebody had testified
uh a set of facts before the grand jury
when in fact the president had not
testified to those facts before the
grand jury the facts that we reported
were right that that little sliver there
about the grand jury was wrong and on
that day
uh
the white house pounced on us once again
because they they realized that we had
made a real mistake the only one we made
is i think in two years of covering the
watergate story but we were afraid we
were gonna have to quit
uh quit the paper but quickly we found
out what the mistake was said in the
paper what it was that it was an error
of attribution amount of substance that
indeed it was about a secret fund that
had paid for the bugging at watergate
and other undercover activities uh
advising the nixon white house
and uh the substance of it was correct
and we moved on from there if there was
a cable network back in 1970 carl that
would uh be able to
give out uh nixon talking points and why
something like this was okay do you
think you'd have been able to do your
reporting and nixon would be out
do you think that would happen
yeah i think we would have been able to
do the recording but i think this is
what's interesting about about my book
chasing history to
the kidney in israel because everything
i know about reporting about journalism
i really learned that this
apprenticeship that i had
at the greatest afternoon paper in
america and the essence of what i
learned with what you see in watergate
what you see in all the president's men
the kind of reporting we did
you don't get the stories by sitting in
the office you go out you knock on
people's doors you go to source after
source after source
you try to put nail down not just a set
of disparate facts but context in
context that's you know lord and i use
the phrase
uh and we've used it for 50 years now
you know we're the best of friends we
talk a couple times a week and and the
phrase we started using was the best
obtainable version of the truth and it's
it's a variation of what i had learned
at the star and that's there we called
it the
complexity of the truth
and this is not a simple business the
simple part is
is the exercises the perseverance
is the going non-stop to get the story
but but the hard part
is really putting all together what it
means and
you know there's a line in this book
and i learned this covering civil rights
because the washington
that i grew up in was a jim crow town i
went to segregated public schools
legally segregated in the capital of the
united states and a lot of my time at
the star bracketed the civil war by
exactly 100 years later but what i
learned especially covering civil rights
was the truth is not neutral the best
obtainable version of the truth is not
about neutrality it's not about putting
50 percent of the story on one side and
50 on the other when you get to the best
obtainable version of the truth you're
deciding what is news
and so let's take your your veiled
example there when you were talking
about a certain kind of
network or whatever
it's not the best obtainable version of
the truth what you see on fox it's
ideologically driven it's totally
one-sided it's not neutral but it's also
not news because they haven't done the
work or the reporting they have no
interest in reporting so
you can see a straight line from what's
in this book this kid with the best seat
in the country covering civil rights
covering jack kennedy's inauguration in
my first days at the paper city editor
said go to the inaugural credit parade
and go to 4th and pennsylvania avenue
cover the crowd call in what you see
don't be fancy about it don't try to
write anything give it to a rewrite man
i have this amazing
uh opportunity
who could imagine a 16 year old kid you
know
how covered kennedy's press conferences
or i went to them uh i covered his
assassination i covered civil rights i
covered plane crashes terrible events
and so it's all about this
apprenticeship so by the time of
watergate and woodrow likes to tell the
story because he was new in the business
at the time but but i've never seen a
reporter quite like woodward and his his
instincts and his drive
but at the same time said hey hey
he had this experience of 12 years
experience at the time of watergate we
were 28 and 29 years old but i had 12
years experience and so the methodology
that we used in watergate is really what
you see in this book about my
apprenticeship at the star which was a
better paper than the washington post
was at the time i was there carl
bernstein chasing history a kid in the
newsroom but you know there are more
than just one
network and different sides if you will
of of the divide and that's where there
is right now in this country uh that
that that do uh the other
side if you will says this is a slanted
opinion because of their way of doing it
and they're both news and so on and so
forth so my question for you is how do
you view the current state
of political if not investigative
journalism within that beltway carl
bernstein
well two aspects to the question the
first is what what is going on in the
country well
you know i i think you've probably heard
me on the air saying for a number of
years we're in a cold civil war in this
country but then that cold civil war was
ignited by trump so we're now in in a
past the point of ignition in this
country in terms of its division in
terms of the uh viciousness of the anger
but what about the reporting what about
the investigative reporting that you've
you cited i would say that the reporting
and the investigative reporting on the
trump presidency is probably the
greatest reporting by the largest number
of news organizations covering the
presidency of my lifetime that almost
everything and they include books as
well
including bob library's book including
all kinds of work by reporters
for
news organizations uh including some
that are considered to be the left and
some are considered to be a little to
the right because the criminality
and the
actually now we know we had a pro a
seditious president of the united states
tradition meaning someone
who
incites uh who actually incites
insurrection so i think that almost
everything we know about the trump
presidency it doesn't come from people
in the trump
administration
telling us what really happened
it hasn't come from the congress in the
united states until very recently we're
seeing some things through investigation
what we know about the trump presidency
we really know from great reporting
you know at the time of watergate we
were out with myself the washington post
we were out on a limb by ourselves for a
number of months and people didn't
believe what we were writing in the
paper through our own investigative
investigative reporting for months and
months and months
the trump presidency
what these investigative reporters and
people covering the white house have put
into their reports on the air in their
newspapers in their news organizations
online
is the best obtainable version of the
truth and it's a remarkable remarkable
achievement all right let me finish with
a piece of cotton candy then um
okay here we go uh i i am um looking in
the uh index of your book and i i didn't
see it either there's no dustin hoffman
in here um no so
uh did you did you talk with him about
your report his portrayal or did were
you part of it in any way shape or form
for the film
okay sure what was that like tell you
about it the first thing is this book
and and it's told in the voice
chasing history
in the newsroom it's told in the voice
of the kid okay not the old man looking
back i love it but but when dustin
hoffman and robert redford uh came to
play woodward and me
they
they lived with us for like six months i
mean not they didn't come back to our
houses at night but every day they spent
with us practically uh dustin he came he
came to the passover seder
at home we would walk around the city
together
we really got to know each other well
and
and
redford and hoffman would ask us
question after question after question
how did you do this how what would what
were your exact words be to each other
and and the great director of the movie
alan kakula followed uh what we had said
the only reason we were willing to sell
the rights to
the book of all the president's members
is if indeed
a movie director and a producer was
willing to stick to the absolute truth
of what that book was and and not
fictionalize it and uh and that's indeed
what what allen pakula the great
director did that's what redford did
that's what hoffman did and one of the
extraordinary things about all the
presidents
and again there's a straight line from
this chasing history book to
uh
to all the president's men in the
watergate coverages
that
the movie and the book the movie
especially of all the president's men
it's not about woodward and me in our
personal lives there's no love story in
it we don't see any girlfriends it's
about the process of reporting
and what a news organization does
and it's again i mean one of these today
in our journalism there's an awful lot
too much
going to google not getting out of the
newsroom and thinking oh i can go to
google and learn all about what's online
and learn people's biographies and
everything about it if google and
wikipedia are right and they're not
always right
but google and the internet are fabulous
reporting tools but they're no
substitute for what you see in that
movie of all the president's men or what
you read in chasing history it's all
about going out and meeting people and
respecting the people you're covering
even if they're if you even if they're
lying to you you know usually people
tell you what they they're
their truth it might not be the truth
but it's your responsibility to then go
to other sources and find out is what
they think is their truth really the
truth and their shades of gray all
through this that's what all the
presidents and then the movie is about
that's what chasing history the book is
so it's really almost
a prequel to all the president's men
because you see this 16 year old kid
that's 17 year old 18 19 learning and
learning and getting these opportunities
uh
that you can could not even imagine
today
you know one of the first weeks that i
was at the paper
it's right before
john kennedy was elected running against
richard nixon
i was asked by
by the head copy was asked i was told go
to burning tree country club we've got a
photographer out there taking pictures
of president eisenhower on the golf
course and i want you to bring back to
the office his rolls of film
so i went out to burning street country
club
and i had a little identification card
from the washington star and i showed it
to the chief caddy and he took me right
to this putting green and 12 feet away
from me with just one secret service man
nearby was the president of the united
states dwight eisenhower sinking butts
and
and you know i was mesmerized i looked
at his hands and and i could see that
you know they had brown spots on his
hands and i made a little dump in my
notebook and the photographer took the
film out of his camera and
gave it to me and and i left it was the
first time i'd ever seen a president of
the united states but imagine that at
age 16 and a few weeks later
a week before the election jack kennedy
came to my high school in silver spring
maryland and the state editor said to me
well ernst you know we've got our top
political reporter covering this event
because the election is going to be very
close between the candidate and nixon
and maryland could even decide the
election so our top political reporter
is going to come to your high school but
why don't you go stay on the grounds and
again cover the crowd and you know the
ground is there and you know the
community and 12 000 people showed up
for this rally and so even in the first
few weeks of my apprenticeship
at the washington star and you can
imagine some of my classmates looking
bug-eyed at me as i'm sitting there with
a reporter's notebook right running
behind behind the candidate for
president of the united states i mean
what you know what a
good thing to be able to do looking back
at it it's this amazing life that you
know that i've been lucky enough to have
but still this occurring at that age is
you know i'm kind of against myself at
the opportunity and what happened in
those years from age 16 to 21. well
congrats on the book uh chasing history
kid in the newsroom greatly appreciate
this chat love to have you on again carl
bernstein and thank you for all your
work
thank you very much
appreciate it that's carl bernstein
everybody check out his book hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here